في الثاني عشر من مايو عام 2008 كانت
الحياه تسير بصوره طبيعيه في محافظه
ونشوان الصينيه هكذا كان الحال بمنتصف
النهار لكن ما حدث حولها الى منطقه منكوبه
بالكامل بعد ان ضربها زلزال مدمر فماذا
حدث
تسبب ضغط الكثافه السكانيه الكبير ووجود
سدود مياه ضخمه بالمحافظه الواقعه ضمن
منطقه جبال جنوب غرب الصين في احداث تصادم
بين الصفائح الارضيه على عمق كبير بلغ
اكثر من 19 كيلومترا تحت سطح الارض احدثت
حركه الصفائح اكثر من 30 هزه ارتداديه
وسجل على اثرها 21 انهيارًا ارضيا كما
تشكلت 34 بحيره من صدوع الانهار والسدود
كان الناس في اعمالهم قبل ان يدركوا ان
شيئا كبيرا قد حدث مشاهد مرعبه عمت في
المكان الاطفال تدافعوا لمغادره المدارس
والكبار تركوا اعمالهم ومركباتهم وفروا
الى الطريق لا احد يعرف ماذا يحدث ولكن
الجميع اي قناه انها كارثه كبيره قدرت قوه
الزلزال الذي شعر به السكان في جميع انحاء
اسيا بنحو ثماني درجات لكن الهزات الاكثر
عنفا س
زلزال الطرق والانفاق وتقطعت خطوط امداد
الطاقه الكهربائيه كما عانى الملايين من
تعطل خدمات توصيل المياه فتحركت الحكومه
الصينيه بسرعه وقامت بنشر 130 الف جندي
وغيرهم من عمال الاغاثه في المنطقه
المنكوبه لكنهم عاجزوا عن الوصول للكثير
من القرى النائيه كما واجهوا نقصا في
المعدات
تسبب زلزال في اضرار في اكثر من 21 مليون
مبنى بينها نحو خمسه ملايين الف منزل
انهارت بالكامل وخمسه ملايين وتسعمائه الف
لم تعد صالحه للسكن ما جعل الملايين من
الناس بلا ماوى
اثر الزلزال على ما يقرب من 224 الف هكتار
من الاراضي الخصبه ودمر نحو 100 الف هكتار
من حقول الارز كما تضررت معدات ومرافق
زراعيه وقنوات الري
كانت مهمه رجال الانقاذ هي الاصعب ففتح
قنوات التصريف تسبب في انهيارات طينيه
وفيضانات واسعه تسببت في مقتل ما لا يقل
عن 200 عنصر من عمال الاغاثه مع انتهاء
عمليات البحث والانقاذ اعتبر ما يقرب من
90 الف شخص في عداد الاموات او المفقودين
ويفترض انهم ماتوا في التقييم النهائي
الرسمي للحكومه الصينيه وشمل اجمالي القتل
المبلغ عنه رسميا اكثر من
5300 طفل معظمهم من طلبه المدارس كما اصيب
ما يقرب من 375 الف شخص بجروح بسبب سقوط
الحطام وانهيار المباني اما حجم المتضررين
فقد تجاوز اربعه وثلاثين مليون شخص
بعد اسبوع من الزلزال اعلنت الصين الحداده
الرسمي لمده ثلاثه ايام على ضحايا الزلزال
قبل ان تبدا عمليه اصلاح واعاده بناء
المساكن والبنيه التحتيه في المناطق
المتضرره وهو ما كبد الاقتصاد الصيني اكثر
من 86 مليار دولار وجعل هذه المحافظه
الصينيه منطقه منكوبه حتى يومنا هذا
[موسيقى]